the unity
of all finding
i'll start this off very explain like
i'm five
so many people know islam
but very few people know sufism
sufism is the mystic school
of islam
mystic simply means becoming one
with god
each major religion has a mystic branch
we've been speaking about that quite a
bit on the show
look at the mystic branches
of the planetary religious traditions
immerse yourself in their teachings
and become one with god
so what that al-wujud
to me for so long
meant the unity of being an existence
god
into many scholars that have been
studying
sufism in this very profound
saying in the sufi metaphysics
means something even deeper
and more profound than this
okay so again
this is absolute oneness
this is creation is not
separate of the absolute god
and creation are one i and my father
are one john 10 30.
okay so what is it that is more deep
and more profound about what al wujud
than the unity of being in existence
it's this
and this is thanks so much
to the ibn arabi society
and william chidix work
in his long
effort filled periods of aiming
to explain what wujud
means he writes
that it's the unity of all
finding and i have this link
in the bio for you to look at
as well you can see here
on the even arabi society.org
page william chidix writing
and what i have highlighted there you
can see
means literally finding and to be found
okay so why
why do i find this to be
so profound
well
what went from a couple days ago for me
which was a
wadat al-wujud meant pretty much
as a saying
a very similar
oneness that all of the other
mystic traditions talk about
so i thought
and this is a big part of the word
hermeneutics
which means interpretations of these
mystic
spiritual traditions because until
somebody like william writes the
translation of wujud in the
interpretation of it
as finding i never
ever encountered this
and i wonder how many other people have
never
encountered this but are familiar with
the sufi metaphysics and are familiar
with
wadat al-wujud because the unity of all
being in existence
means oneness means god absolute oneness
it's a common
perennial wisdom from the spiritual
mystic traditions
but but
when you change woojude
to mean finding
when
i was first a couple days ago
reading this
what happened to me was so fascinating
i've never felt this before
my entire nervous system went into shock
i began gasping for a breath
it was very loud it was like
it was like that and i
curled over into the fetal position
and i began crying
and slowly augmenting my
perception my conceptual frameworks
to the next level
i literally leveled up as a character
and it was a very clear and profound
leveling up
i was in complete awe in
shock my whole body was in complete
shock and it went on
for 10 minutes and then further
throughout the day i continued the
process of having these flashbacks to
this most
profound revelation and leveling up that
i had went through
okay so what
how did i augment my
frameworks my
understanding of reality
and who we are and why we're here
to such degree that this happened
okay i will explain that now
as you may know
i've been very adamant about how
are our
traumas are our greatest
treasures and that we
must share the wisdoms that we've
learned with the world
and how the the lotus flower
it grows out of muddy waters
and how diamonds
form under intense
pressure and temperature
and it's a very strong analogy for
humans
we ourselves are diamonds
that form under intense
temperature and pressure
and we make a diamond cameo
of sorts
and i've tried to
i will show you a small visualization
here in a moment
but so what what that aloo jude
means
is the sum of
all unveiling and finding
i'm sorry it's beautiful but
holy cow it's coming again so
and i'm sharing it i'm sharing this
revelation this leveling up
with the world here it's beautiful
okay so
that means
the sum of all unveiling
and finding so every single
one of us
undergoing our own unique
process
of slowly piercing
the veil of who we truly
are
and finding the truth
and i already can feel that there is
going to be a
an amount of people that
watch that very
quickly think about it and get it
thinking about something like all eight
billion people
on the planet undergoing their own
unique
process of communion their own
unique process of unveiling and finding
and that entire summation of all of the
phenomenology and all of the qualia
some people are going to get that right
away
and other people won't
and that's okay because you will likely
come back to this video
in a year or you might come back to this
video in two years
and what's going to happen is down the
line when you come back to this video
you will understand this
it has happened to me over and over
again where i watched a piece of content
from two years ago
and thought that i understood it
and then i came back to it this year
watched it again and my mind was
blown
okay so
i'm going to aim to visually share this
with you as well
there's a very special way of
understanding this
junaid has this quote
the water takes on the color of the cup
that very deeply resonates with how
that oneness that infinite
one infinite creator expressing itself
takes on the color of all of these
different cups
all of these different creations all of
these different unique
individual expressions within the
creation
and that it also means that
the divine epiphany
is received in limitless combinations
it's colored by that person's nature
so that means again this idea of
the each unique
sentient agent each
unique conscious agent undergoes their
own
unique unveiling and finding
of a union a yoga
with the one infinite creator
and it's going to be colored by that
person's nature i'm going to have a
different one than someone else that's
born in a different country in a
different culture
who's a different age that's had a
different
familial lineage that's led them to
where they're at today
and i love this phrase the divine
epiphany
because that is what it is it's the
divine epiphany of the
understanding of our true nature who we
are
why we're here
and it's received in these limitless
combinations
and that's why the phrase is so
profound because it's the summation of
all of the limitless combinations of
unveiling and finding how [ __ ]
profound is that
it's not just your own it's not just
oneness
first of all it's not just oneness which
is what we think
the term means oneness oneness of being
oneness of existence
it's a very common theme from the
perennial spiritual traditions
so you just use the word like you use it
from all the other traditions
but now that you know that means finding
now that you know what's the summation
of all unveiling and
finding now it's profoundly different
the hermeneutic the interpretation of
the
profound spiritual saying what that
always
has taken on a completely different
concept
in your soul
it makes me wonder of all of the unique
unions that are happening across the
world all of the unique unions
every single one of these unique humans
each one is a unique conscious agent
that is having their
own process of their sentience
unveiling and finding the true nature of
their reality the true nature of the
self
the true nature of that one infinite
creator
and that's so profound okay
alright so i promised i was going to
give you some
a little bit of a visual to understand
this as well so
this brings a whole new meaning to my
design for chapter 9 on consciousness
so as many of you know i published high
level perception
the visual synthesis on the nature of
reality synthesizing signs of
spirituality
and meeting basic needs maximizing human
potential
and what
i did was in chapter 9 on consciousness
i specifically made
this visual in my aim to attempt
to create a hypothesis of what i thought
consciousness could be interpreted as
especially given
an aim to synthesize it with science
with physicalism
and especially in this case you see that
i'm even adding the an
integral sign which is borrowed from
calculus in this case which means the
summation of infinitesimal data so in
this case we're summing
all of the phenomenologies all of the
sentience all of the qualia
from all of the conscious agents on the
planet which is that zero to eight
billion
and those are each like nerve endings of
the one infinite creator which is like
this brain that you see here
and so what this means is that we're
slowly moving
what i think from this and i i didn't
mention for those that don't know this
i also explain the derivation or the
differentiation or the individuation as
well
so where the integral in the calculus of
consciousness
is the 99.9
genetic similarity on a dna level
between all humans the
0.1 genetic difference is the
individuation so that's the unique gift
that people are bringing into the world
people are contributing different
in the symphony in the integration in
the ocean in the oneness
people are unique solos they are playing
unique
melodies they are playing unique
instruments in that
and so that's your unique gift your
unique north star that you contribute
that's a very self-actualization that's
that derivation versus the
self-realization is the integration
okay so now what
al-wujud does to this
is it takes it to the next level
and so it would look
it would look something like this
so i haven't hashed this out completely
yet but i wanted to at least
give you an idea of what i was i was
beginning to represent it as
so as you can see up there right here
specifically
you see that same style earth but now
instead of seeing the nerve endings
it's like nerve endings that are also
ascending
and becoming diamonds so now
i want you to visualize i want you to
sorry i want you to visualize
eight billion humans that are ascending
and becoming diamonds
that are having their diamond cameos
the unity of all finding eight billion
people finding
and those being like diamonds and the
summation of all of that
and so this is very much i wrote this a
little bit up here the diamond is the
cosmic force and this is very similar to
the
term prana which means breath or life
force or chit agni
tapas which means consciousness force
so
so that's just the that's just the
beginning
of aiming to artistically
explain what i believe wahat al-wujud
truly means by the unity of all finding
so
again when i
in i had this conceptual
visualization of the 8 billion humans on
the planet
that were undergoing phenomenology of
sorts
and i knew that they were undergoing
some sort of
yoga union
but what al wujud the unity of all
finding
when i read this it
made it very clear the role that
finding has in
the creation with the 8 billion
conscious agents are
undergoing a process of piercing the
veil
of finding what the true
self is
and there's a beautiful
unfolding that happens of each sentient
agent
undergoing their own unique process of
that self-realization
of one infinite creator and
self-actualization of a unique
contributory gift
and becoming a very clear channel a
clear vessel
for that contributory gift
through that cosmic life force that's
unfolding
but we usually clog up that channel
in so many ways based on our
process of not actually having undergone
self-realization
so it brought a whole new meaning
because i actually visualized all
for the first time ever i visualized all
eight billion sentient agents
on the planet undergoing a diamond
style ascension all if you can imagine
eight billion
diamonds currently forming on the planet
that's what i got from what jude
that's what i got eight
billion diamonds currently forming on
the planet
and that is the unity of all finding
each unique conscious agent undergoing
their own unique
combination and experience and
phenomenology
of finding of piercing the veil and
finding
and when i felt that that's why my
nervous system went into shock because i
had
never felt that specific before
not that specific i hadn't visualized
all eight billion as
diamonds undergoing that process
before all with their own unique
combination of finding
never that was my first time
so what being the unity of all finding
for me is much different than the unity
of all being in existence
way different the unity of all being in
existence again
is just very oceanic oneness which is a
common
perennial spiritual tradition wisdom
across the mystic lineages on the planet
but the unity of all finding
that specific word finding again
the hermeneutic the interpretation the
words we use
are so important changing from
um from being in existence
to finding is a
massive change in symbology semiotics
meaning interpretation completely
different
from me completely different
and it was so profoundly awakening
okay wow well
i'm glad that it's coming out in a good
flow
and i wonder how many other people are
being affected this way by it i would
love to know in the comments below
if you are being profoundly affected by
this
and give me specifics i would love
to know and i would love to share
because there's so much that needs of
this
style of awakening of realization
that must be shared and popularized in
the mainstream culture so we need to do
it together as a community so do comment
below
let me know
the highest folk have found god and
anchor it on earth and that's that
tantric tradition
that's the idea of weaving we talk about
that all the time you must
anchor your profound self-realizations
in the social fabric
in your self-actualizations you must
anchor
it in the knot of life you must
butterfly effect out the highest level
of morality
the highest level of being the highest
level
of virtue the highest level of ethic
everything you touch
must be from the gold realization
of the true one infinite creator and you
act as a channel you
act as a vessel to butterfly affect that
out to everything around you
because you know the self in the other
you know that that is an other self and
you see that and you know that
and it's funny because even saying the
words you see the self
in the other you see the other as an
other self
even those words are so interesting to
me because i promise you
a year ago i wouldn't have really got it
two years ago especially i wouldn't have
got it
but now i get it i [ __ ]
get it and i'm so grateful that i do
and it's time for me to share it with
others because i [ __ ] get it
i've experientially felt it in my core
i know it i'm a gnostic individual
and so now it's my role to share it
and again this video might land with you
you might say that ah great i found
somebody else that knows as well
which is great welcome to the community
you might say
kind of get it a little bit maybe chunks
and pieces which might be what i would
have been like a year ago
so continue undergoing your processes
that you're going
and check back in potentially with this
content in a year and for those of you
that
absolutely don't get what i'm saying
whatsoever
it would be good potentially you may be
people that are
hyper analytical you may be hyper
intellectual you might be hyper
scientific people and
there are ways for you to understand the
unity of all being existence
which is a perennial spiritual mystic
truth across the traditions of the whole
planet
that are scientifically literate so
there are ways for you to understand
this oneness from a very scientific
perspective and i've talked about this a
lot in my videos
but just to help you out so that you can
potentially work your way up as
baby steps to understanding these
spiritual self-realizations as well
you literally can't take a breath
without
the interdependent relationship
that we have on the photosynthesis
that's happening
around the planet so literally the
phytoplankton and the
trees around the planet are producing
the oxygen that you're inhaling
20 000 times a day
so there's a true unity of being in
existence the 20 000 breasts that you
rely on per day are literally coming
from the photosynthesis
of phytoplankton and trees
you know or think about another one
every single time that you take a bite
of food or take a sip of water when does
that bite of food or that sip of water
become you
how porous are you we talk about this a
lot actually in our project and we have
really good visuals for this to explain
it
but here we're looking at another visual
from chapter nine this one's on identity
this one's on porosity
you know do you identify yourself as a
more porous as a more perforated
individual like the person here on the
left who understands what i was saying
about
the interdependent relationship on the
planetary
oxygenation that cycle that we
take from the photosynthesis that's
happening and how we breathe out co2 and
then that's their source
to continue the cycle and the same
things with the food in the water
how much of the food and the water
do you understand is actually part of
the oneness
versus how much do you think that it's a
separate item
an individual item when does that item
become you when you take the bite of the
apple when your body
actually undergo cellular respiration
and turns the glucose into atp
does it then become you does the apple
then become you when does it become you
how about with the water the same water
that
dinosaurs were drinking 66 million years
ago as part of the same hydrological
cycle today
so when does that water become you once
it goes in your mouth once it lands in
your body and hydrates you
how about the microbiome the symbiotic
relationship that you have with your
gut how about that how about the bill
how about the 1 000
species of bacteria that are in there
that each have 2
000 genes so there's 2 million total
gene expressions down there
which is 100 times more than the 20 000
human gene expressions
which means that this is a very crazy
symbiotic relationship so where
where where's the line of separation
what does u mean
right so if you're coming from a
scientific an analytical and
intellectual angle
do you find yourself like this character
on the right do you walk around with a
box
around your head all day thinking that
you're a separate entity in a separate
random nihilistic existence
because you're not you're absolutely
not we are the one infinite creator
expressing itself we've eternally been
doing this and we will continue doing
this forever
this is what we do this is how we know
ourself
this is how we play this is the games
that we do
and you're going to continue seeing this
over and over again you we just don't
know
yet because this is the thing is that
you think that you you think that you
birth
and you think that you die but really
what we
hypothesize is that your awareness
actually
never ends your awareness
never ends and there's just
you don't remember on either side of it
it's hard to remember a lot of people
remember a lot of people dive in and
remember this type of stuff
and we need to scientifically validate
this through the scientific method
you know the dalai lama and panch and
lama have a very interesting process the
tibetan book of the dead they have a
very interesting process that we can
scientifically investigate deeper
but as hyper analytical
hyper-intellectual hyper-scientific
people i would recommend the process of
at least
understanding your level of perforation
and your level
of identity are you identified with an
ego are you identified
in a box or are you becoming a little
bit more porous do you understand the
things that i'm saying about the
interconnectedness of
all existence the interconnectedness of
your breath of your water of your food
of your relationship with your
microbiome because if you start
understanding those things
you will open yourself up slowly more
and more
when you speak to somebody when you're
sitting there and you're listening
wherever you are you're listening or
you're watching
i am literally affecting your
neurophysiology
period i'm affecting you right now
and the same thing's true about when
someone's on the show and they're
speaking to me
they're affecting me and so
we're in this constant process of
undergoing
some sort of a planetary it's a
synthesis
of the of the biological evolution and
a style of like exposomics that's
occurring so the biological organisms
are exposed to their environments and
their environments are exposing them
all the time there's a complete unity of
all being in existence a single
planetary symbiosis
evolution that's occurring and to
be blinded to that is to be blind to the
nature of our existence
and so i do my best to help
uplift people through whatever means
whatever baby steps they have to take
in order to slowly begin grasping some
of these more intense
metaphysical concepts like the unity of
all being in existence
and that's just you know work that's
still one
step below apparently than the unity of
all finding which is one step above
that which is crazy which i just got to
a couple days ago
so work your way up
this this ladder message me where you're
at
message me in the comments below where
you're at if you're if you can resonate
scientifically at least with some of
these concepts i'm talking about
i will gladly help you get to some of
the next
rungs on the ladder okay if you're
already deep in the spiritual mystic
traditions and this is
already resonating fantastic and we had
that small
aside for people that are working their
way up the ladder
i love you so much thank you for being
here
and hopefully i'll do better over time
at
explaining this to as many
people in terms of uplifting and and and
helping as possible
you'll see that's actually one of the
interesting quotes that we'll get to
towards
the later stages here
okay so
jude is not just there to be found
it also finds and this is where we see
the phenomenon
of a complex system and an attractor
and what this means is it means that
in the most simple way possible we are
a pinnacle of evolutionary
synthesis that's happened on this planet
of
evolutionary unfolding we are a pinnacle
of that
okay we are as i write here awareness
consciousness
is essential okay so once this sentience
evolves this awareness consciousness
that gets to reflect on its own
existence evolves you've really reached
a pinnacle point in evolution this is
very good that we're here
this is exactly what we plan this is
fantastic
and so what this is is this is a complex
system okay so this biological evolution
is what is called a complex system
okay and then there's a uh
in mathematics is called a strange
attractor and it's just what a complex
system evolves towards
but would do it is not just the complex
system evolves towards
it but that the attractor itself is
constantly in a process
of drawing their meeting and drawing
their meeting and drawing and drawing
going upwards together towards this god
head that we're evolving towards
and we've hypothesized in many of our
other videos like the actual nature of
reality where we talk about
that auroboro style godhead that we're
evolving towards which we hypothesize is
a metaverse
recursion i won't get into that too much
here but it just means the synthesis
of artificial general intelligence neuro
and biotech like neurolink and stuff
like that
and then the indistinguishable virtual
realities
and so we may be going inward into those
indistinguishable virtual worlds which
is potentially
exactly where we came from okay so that
might be
a potential solution for the nature
of our existence and why we are so drawn
to this technological singularity that
we're building
so that's profound so jude in a sense
is both the complex systems evolution
and the process of the conscious agent
itself that aims to pierce the veil and
understand its own nature
and it's also the attractor itself that
is
also constantly in relationship with
that sentient agent which is fascinating
and then we have some more incredible
wisdom that shut on us here
our whole problem is that god is with
us but we are not with him
and in the quran he is with you wherever
you are
so all right what this means is that
i'll break this down also as we keep
going but
the general idea is that everyone
is already it okay you're already
it everyone is already it okay we all
are it already okay
but the thing is is that a lot of people
haven't made the realization that
they're already it
okay and that's why people are
undergoing such
insane processes of like wanting to
you know go and have one night stands on
different social platforms or
they want to get undergo some sort of
insane
constant use of a substance to try and
get them to
a place of being high when really the
reality
is is that you're already it you just
don't know it yet you haven't realized
it and you have to undergo a process of
realizing it
and that's why the direct path exists
the direct path is basically
the most direct teachings of
self-realization
like modernity has absolutely no time
to go to the 10-day theravada buddhism
meditation retreats where there's no
talking no eye contact no technology
i've set four times and i love those
because they train a lot of other
important faculties
yet modernity doesn't have a lot of the
energy
that's required to do that and so
and the economic machinery is very much
so choking this out of people and so
that's why you have
the fantastic work of people again
that i've mentioned on the show so much
is go check out rupert spyra's
youtube channel he's one of the leading
advice of a daunted teachers right now
the
the leading non-dual direct
path teachings also another one is
bentino masaro in his mirror talks
podcast he's another one of the leading
spiritual synthesis
and teachers right now go and watch
their channels and practice
learning from other people that are at
the edge that are trying to help with
these direct path teachings
because all it literally requires is you
to reflect
on your own awareness if you reflect on
your own awareness your own
consciousness
and you do that deeply enough what's
going to happen is you're going to
realize how
first principled your awareness and your
consciousness is
and then you're going to realize that ah
this is the nature of reality
and once you get that click then you
realize okay
so i am actually i am that
i am that sentience is it awareness is
it okay there's that first realization
and then you have the realization that
i've always been doing this
i am that one infinite creator i am you
you
are me all eight billion of us are
sentient which means that we are all god
god is the sentience awareness that's
infinitely exploring creations
and we are that and so there are a
couple of these like
levels of of in full embodied gnosis but
that's your general
that's your general process towards that
more god consciousness state of
existence
because you deserve it you deserve it
you deserve to not
as bentino masara as this really great
analogy you deserve to not be in a state
of bliss
for just a couple minutes every day
you deserve to be in a state of bliss
all day long
every day you deserve it we all do
and so this is the thing is that you can
literally live from a place of bliss
and peace and harmony and ecstasy and
being high on the nature of existence
on a 24 7 level but in order for you to
get to that point you have to realize
that you're it
and it's a direct path teaching you
don't need to go and sit for 10 days
you don't need to undergo a heroic dose
of psilocybin you don't need to do these
things
you can you can supplement your direct
path teaching
with theravada buddhism retreat i highly
recommend that
i also highly recommend anthogens in a
very
smart way of undergoing set process
so there's many modalities that you can
undertake that will actually make you a
more
well versed embodied
individual of the one infinite creator
all right and so the sufi
metaphysics have a really good way of
also explaining this with words
they have hadra which is he is with us
and then
which is the achievement of the vision
of god's presence
so you'll see there are so many people
around the world
that talk about oh god is with us god is
with us
god is with us and you'll kind of tell
that they've like externalized some sort
of like entity
that is that is someone that is not
within
them so that they've externalized it
right this is what
a lot of the perverse incentives and the
religious foundations
do they have dogmas and fundamentalism
that are not the mystic traditions the
mystic traditions are where
all of the top flavored ice cream is at
and that's the perennial spiritual
wisdom is that they're all different
flavors of ice cream that are all
talking about the unity of being in
existence the unity of finding
but the perverse incentives are things
like where they externalize god
and that they say that he is with us he
is with us and then
is when you yourself have achieved the
vision of god's presence
that's when you've done that process
that i outlined a moment ago
that's when you've investigated the
nature of your own awareness and
consciousness to the degree of where you
realize you
are the one infinite creator that's
and so it's important to have that
distinction so when you see people
walking around with
chanting like hadra you can nudge you
can see what you can do asking questions
vibing with them and see if you can get
them to undergo hudor instead
okay so god is present with us
is not the same as saying that we are
present with him
another very profound and easy way of
understanding it
so you want to get to a point where you
say we are present with
him that that god is inside of me leo
tolstoy the kingdom of god
is within you you want to get to that
level
and then presence with god needs to be
achieved
yoga union in sanskrit
it is the object of the spiritual quest
the whole
problem is that people are not present
with
the god who is present with them
so again you wonder like out of those 8
billion
on the unity of all finding the jude you
wonder okay out of the eight billion
well how many of those sentient agents
are actually
present with the kingdom of god within
how many of them are present with
being the one infinite creator versus
how many of them
are still veiled and how can we
accelerate the process of them
shattering the veil piercing
the veil awakening to being the one
infinite creator
themselves and that's the essence of the
show
that's the essence of simulation that's
the essence of
my ethos that's the essence of our
show's ethos
this is exactly what we care about this
is exactly why we're here in la
to penetrate the celebrity level
consciousness at this level
it's one of the big reasons why we're
here we have a lot of other projects
that we're cooking up in the
animated series space and lots of other
things that i've talked about on the
program
okay let's keep rolling so again we're
going to revisit this so
in this case we're going to use english
words to describe it to so
uh a single english word to describe the
two so we have hadra
which can be thought of as domain and
then
hudur which can be thought of as
presence and
presence is really important because you
can describe it with the opposite
which is absence and that's haiba
and so what's going on is you have a
a spectrum like we were describing
earlier of where people are
hyper present with the one infinite
creator versus they're absent of the one
infinite creator
and people that are absent of the one
infant creator are usually the ones with
the box around their head like we were
illustrating earlier
okay so you can take these little
scientific incremental steps even to
realize slowly
more and more the unity of all being in
existence and you can slowly
incrementally work your way even
scientifically intellectually and
rationally
up the ladder slowly analytically you
know you can do it
you can do it and so there's these
varying degrees of presence
and absence
okay so let's review
the unity of all finding the sum
of unveiling and finding the unity of
all achievement of the vision of god's
presence
the sum of presence and absence
the divine knowledge embraces all
things so again it's very much like the
integral
in calculus it's very much like the
summation of all phenomenological
experience the summation of all qualia
all 8 billion conscious agents plus all
10 million other species on the planet
undergoing the process of awakening to
the nature of their existence and being
slowly over time more and more and
that's that
attractor and that's our sentence and
the relationship between them
everything is always finding it's always
perfect
you can use your free will to
self-realize
you can diamond cameo faster and so this
is where
we sometimes get into some of the
semantics and syntax and so i'm going to
be very surgical and careful here for
you
so by saying you are already it and by
saying that everything's already perfect
that does not mean that you don't have
to realize that you are the one infinite
creator
you can literally use your free will
right now
to self-realize that you are it but you
have to undergo that process of
realizing it
you can't stay with a box around your
head as an egoic level of consciousness
and assume that
that ah okay great i'm already it so
i'll just stay in my ego and i'll keep
self dealing to myself and that's all
that's all she wrote excellent uh no
that's not what that means that means
that you
can at any moment you want leverage your
free will
and undergo the process of
self-realization
now there are many different paths like
we were saying in up this mountain
towards this realization and so i again
highly recommend
undergoing some of these direct path
teachings they're very simple
they're very intuitive you have to use
your intuition
you have to have faith this isn't some
this is
this is super rational it's beyond the
rational you have to use your intuition
you have to have
faith that this is not an accident
that it's the beautiful summation of all
sentient experience that's occurring on
the planet
is literally god undergoing the process
of
infinite expression and that this is
just one combination
of that infinite expression that's being
underwent and so
this is the type of thing we have to
have faith in order for us to
truly intuitively anchor inside of
ourselves
and i love these words us
infinite self disclosure an infinite
self
unveiling there's no lack
so it's just an endless amount of self
unveiling an endless amount of self
disclosure is just
us realizing the nature of our existence
cyclically in different combinations of
realities that we design
it's fascinating it's like the coolest
possible thing that could
exist is this one infinite creator that
plays
hide and seek with itself that explores
infinity
that explores infinite phenomenological
states of existence
because you can never explore all
phenomenological states
it's going to take you forever to
explore all phenomenologies
and so everything that i'm experiencing
throughout my lifetime
is just one exploration of phenomenology
and you have to think beyond this like
this is a four-limbed
two-eyed carbon-based dna encoded
soul vehicle in a three space with one
time
reality right like you you got it
there's quantum mechanics in this one
there's
there's natural selection in this one
you gotta think of like
going beyond use like walt disney use
your
creative imagination be like pixar go
way beyond what this reality like think
like the midnight gospel
right you have to think at that level to
think like okay well what are all the
other
styles of universe you have to be like a
video game designer that's designing
different
realities for conscious agents to
immerse themselves in for sentience to
slowly awaken to the fact that it
is already that one infinite creator and
excuse me we're going to see more and
more of that as we make our
indistinguishable virtual realities
because that will in itself be an
awakening mechanism to what this already
is
okay and here's where you're gonna get
that same thing that i've been saying
no one is more ignorant than he
who seeks god
however it remains for you to recognize
him
i'm just gonna leave that one so
profound
and that same sentence is going to apply
however it remains for you to recognize
them that's going to keep
applying throughout all these these are
all sufi metaphysics quotes
so this is an accumulation of the most
profound sufi metaphysics thinkers
okay and the translations that people
have been passing down for centuries
the one who is completely ignorant is he
who seeks what is already there
and that's the famous roomie quote that
we talk about on the show all the time
you walk around from room to room
looking for the diamond necklace that is
already
around your neck
he who is certain of emergence will
never seek assent
but yet remember keep in mind however it
remains for you to recognize
that you are the one infinite creator
wherever you turn there is the face of
god
you are at him from the first step which
is
the first breath
jeez this one's so mind-blowing okay
my gosh all right you're ready
at the highest stage of self-knowledge
the gnostics recognize
their own nature as the infinite
and never-ending self-disclosures
of god
and that's why the idea of this
metaverse recursion being at our godhead
is so tasty and it feels so right and
that's why
sir roger penrose who won the nobel
prize in physics in 2020
has a conformal cyclic cosmology theory
so he believes in cyclic cosmology and
he's at the edge of physics in science
and so he believes now what all the
perennial spiritual traditions have been
talking about
for the longest time for thousands of
years
and so it is the idea that we are
infinite and never-ending
self-disclosures of god in all of these
different realities that we design in
all these different vehicles that
sentience takes
you just have to expand your imagination
and have faith in the fact that we are
way beyond just this one creation
way beyond just this one creation and
that's when you also get into some of
the phenomenon around quantum
entanglement we're still trying to
figure that out what that actually means
the multiverse and the parallel
realities all these type of things
and so that's sort of its own
interesting
aspect to what this perennial spiritual
traditions
have been saying
here's another great one all light is
one
but colors a thousand fold
and that's also very deeply related to
the source light that goes and refracts
in the prism
into the rainbow of colors
the all of being that our being resides
in
be thou in union if you wish or if you
wish in distinction
through both obtain a great success
if you profess both you have been shown
the right way
you are a leader in the gnostic sciences
a master
my heart has become capable of every
form i follow
the religion of love and this is where
the quote about simultaneity being key
this is where you can be a self-realized
immersed in the non-dual symphony ocean
that's occurring
while simultaneously being a
self-actualizing conscious agent
that is bringing some sort of divine
transcendent noble aim north star
solo melody instrument that you're
playing into the world that brings value
into
your life your families like the
community's life and the planet's life
you can hold both of those
simultaneously
and that's why that's why we made
that's why we made this graphic because
we knew that
we knew that people were going to be for
the longest time trying to figure out
well why like if you like you know you
have this famous
two quotes up here you have parmenidus
that says all apparent change is merely
illusion you have heraclitus that says
punta ray everything flows
and it's merely just this on one the
human the soul vehicle
the sentient agents they find themselves
right in the middle
always non-dual spiritual
symphony and on the other side is the
physical
the individual the solo they find
themselves
right in the middle and so you're just
constantly right there
and that's continuously going to be
likely one of the core
processes of sentience likely there's
probably lots of other ways to undergo
this process but
this appears to be our combination
and likely many others the illusory
individual sentient agents in the
oneness that seems like one of the best
that's why sri aurobindo and the mother
mira alfasa have the famous quote
which is diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of the infinite so
meaning diversity
is constantly the form that the oneness
expresses
in order for it to have a large sentient
realization of itself across all these
different combinations
all right oh this one's good
oh i'm pumped for you guys okay
then the eye of certainty opens and
staring inwardly at himself he finds
himself lost
vanished but he finds the friend
and when he looks still deeper realizes
the friend
is himself he exclaims
beloved i sought you here and there
asked for news of you from all i met
then i saw you through myself and found
we were identical now i blush
to think i ever searched for signs
of you
my goodness i'm telling you man the sufi
metaphysics are
so saturated full of wisdom that
the west needs to dig into more and
appreciate more
the whole planet needs to know yourself
and you shall know your lord
only when the other vanishes
is their union
he wished to be a source of hope
for all created beings
we have sent you only as a mercy towards
the worlds
lastly above all
what you need is high morals
and that naturally comes with the
process
of self-realization you naturally
butterfly effect out
the highest morals the highest ethics
the highest levels of being
all right so shouting out
even arabi and the society
the links in the bio below also william
chidik
so he's the philosopher writer
translator and interpreter of classical
islamic philosophical and mystical texts
and uh he also wrote that presence with
god link that's
available in the bio so highly recommend
check checking that out
i also want to shout out my boy phillip
holm from sweden he runs this
youtube channel called let's talk
religion on youtube his work's fantastic
i just became a patron after watching my
his one of
the first video i've ever watched of his
today and i highly recommend um watching
his content he has a really good new
video on the vedas as well which i
highly recommend watching
he does it from a very very literate uh
spiritual perspective it's it's super
interesting
and he parses for salience really well
so shout out to him
again william chitik shout out to you as
well
i'm gonna send you the link to this and
i hope that you will
come on the show even if we do it
remotely i know it will be very
important for me to talk to you
and in general the imna robbie society
shout out to you guys as well thank you
so much
and hopefully we can feature more of the
the sufi
metaphysical leaders worldwide
so so yeah so that's um
you know that's that's that's a big
that's pretty much it
i wanna maybe overview a couple of these
things
before we wrap i love this all light is
one but color is a thousand fold
such a perfect way to describe the
expressions that we undergo in this one
as well
gnostics recognize their own nature as
the
infinite and never-ending
self-disclosures of god
perfect wherever you turn there's the
face of god
and just again just to be very clear
this quote
no one is more ignorant than he who
seeks god
that really resonates with people
especially for those that have already
recognized
the one infinite creator but you have to
recognize the one infinite creator for
that to make sense
you have to undergo that process and
then it'll make sense
the unity of all finding the sum of
unveiling and finding the unity of all
achievement of the vision of god's
presence
excuse me
the sum of presence and absence the
divine knowledge embraces all things
i'll definitely show you guys that
graphic again to help with this
our whole problem is that god is with us
but we are not with him
highest focus found god and anchored on
earth
the divine epiphany is received in
limitless
combinations colored by that person's
nature
the water takes on the color of the cup
of that one
the sum of unveiling and finding
we all make a diamond cameo
i'll be super interested to know how
many people have reactions like this
be super interesting or whatever various
scales of reactions
the unity of all finding so profound
so profound
okay so again visual super important
the unity of all finding what does that
mean
that means this
that means the unity of all sentient
agents the unity of all conscious agents
the unity of all sentience
finding piercing the veil
and finding that it is the one infinite
creator
that's what it means and you can
visualize that
you can visualize that like this over
here
where it's eight billion humans
that are each undergoing this ascension
to diamond
undergoing this diamond ascension the
whole process being a diamond ascension
the whole process being the whole
process being a finding
of finding a finding over time that
becomes more and more awakened that
pierces the veil more and more over time
imagine
8 billion of these diamonds constantly
forming
around the planet and and the summation
of those 8 billion diamonds
and then that's the diamond is the
cosmic force
just super super interesting as a
hypothesis
and i have faith that that is the actual
nature of reality i just also am very
non-dogmatic and i'm very very
non-dogmatic
and i'm very scientifically literate
hypothesis driven as well so very
excited to leverage the tools of the
scientific method to be able to
uh probe at this at as much as we can of
this as well but i also realize the
intuitive faith that is needed
simultaneously
all right what that allows you the unity
of all finding thank you everyone for
tuning in greatly appreciate it and if
you if you haven't already
i highly recommend diving into the
planetary mystic schools as well
as great as sufism is which is the
mystic school of islam
which is fantastic i just want to be
clear
that there are mystic schools
which again means becoming one with god
there are mystic schools for
every single one of the planetary
spiritual traditions for a vast majority
of them
the main ones especially okay so if you
haven't yet go and look these up
so for hinduism we have advaita vedanta
again advaita vedanta go look that up i
mentioned that for
rupert spyra right and then we have
for buddhism we have zokchan
and zen and zen look those up
and then if you haven't read the doubter
ching by lao tza
read that from taoism read that super
short
read that super short and you can find a
very quick um
also uh version of it as well on audible
as well that's like a two-hour synthesis
of the key points
you absolutely have to intake that
and then uh confucianism has a bunch of
good
aspects to it as well to check out in
the four books and five classics you can
get a lot of good stuff around
morality especially from that and then
in the
we already listed in the abrahamics we
listed sufism
from islam but then we'll also list from
the judeo-christian traditions we have
gnosticism
from christianity and then we have
hasidism
and we have kabbalah from judaism so go
and look those up
and then we have the vodon vodun
tradition of the african atlantic
traditions check those out
and then we have the entheogenic this is
the north and south american the
entheogenic
as well as the sweat lodge as well as
the potlatch
there's many unique expressions of it in
the
in the americas as well and these are
just a limited amount there's the
aborigines
in australia and there's a lot of other
pockets of indigenous people
around the planet in different areas
that have their own ideas of what union
with god is becoming one with god that's
why the word
yoga means union the west turned yoga
into holding stretching positions which
is
funny because that is a you know core
part of the process but
the most core part of yoga means union
union with the divine union with god
that's what it means
and so just remember that next time you
hear somebody talking about
yoga just check in do you know what yoga
means
uh no i don't it means union in sanskrit
it means union with god union with the
divine and when
when the person hears that depending on
their vibe they'll likely
you know be like oh that's cool like now
i know you know so
so pass that around to more people out
there and as cool as what that always
the unity of all finding is i promise
you that if you do
a dive into the planetary mystic
traditions
if you even spend you know a week or a
little bit longer if you can
diving into the depths of them and if
you can immerse yourself in their
retreats
and their teachings in the depths what
will happen
is you'll as long as you especially if
you parse out the
top most profound teachings and the top
most profound words and the top most
profound embodied
learnings from those traditions what
will happen is you will very
quickly rocket yourself up to a
self-realization
and so just pass that time studying the
planetary mystic traditions
and you'll ramp you'll get up to
self-realization it'll just click
it'll be like the direct path it'll
click and by the way i've had
many upgrades in perception i've had
many level
ups that have happened right i never
knew what that
would meant the unity of all findings so
i had never thought of the unity of
all sentience finding its one infinite
creator
i i hadn't thought of it that way before
and so there's you know although
i had thought of myself as quite
self-realized a couple days ago i
leveled up my amount of self-realization
so it's also a constant process that we
have to understand that
you know you're both already perfect and
this is the enigma
right this is the mystery of our
beautiful reality is that
you're both already perfect as the one
infinite creator but you're also a
constant work in progress you're
constantly re-baselining yourself to
higher and higher levels of
self-realized
beingness in the world and
self-actualizing more and more of the
highest
morality possible so
keep that in mind along your journey so
that's it i love you very much
thank you for tuning in everyone super
duper appreciate it
and i'm really grateful that you got to
basically
hear what was probably like
one of the most profound experiences of
my life
period and it was so profound
and i think another interesting thing
that i wrote
is that and i don't know if anyone got a
chance to read this
because it was kind of it's kind of
buried in the corner a little bit
but
i wrote that we are logging these most
profound life experiences
into the metaverse catalog like when i
learned
the unity of all finding
which basically what i mean by that is
that we are logging this this is kind of
interesting
we are logging the most profound life
experiences that we have
in our like 80-year chunk of life we are
logging those experiences into a
metaverse catalog
and then we can kind of go and replay
and revisit the
phenomenological states that we
felt during those periods of time
because you know how people say like oh
my gosh if i could bottle up that
feeling and if i could reap if i could
revisit it in the future
given my recency bias i understand that
it was very profound and it was very
recent just a couple days ago that it
happened
but that was one of the most meaningful
most profound experiences in my life and
it might even rank
as it could possibly be it's really
close to the most profound experience of
my life
because again i'm just telling you once
you find once you get the unity of all
finding
it is literally that profound
um and so i think it's possible that we
sort of catalog these most profound
phenomenological states that we undergo
into a big catalog
that we can then explore which i think
is going to happen as we enter into
these
indistinguishable virtual worlds that
we're going to have some sort of a
relationship with
the metaverse that's like that where we
can basically we've talked about this on
the program quite a bit before but
it's basically like a qualia catalog
it's like push button qualia we can like
jump to all of these different
phenomenological experiences which is a
really fun part of
you know consciousness exploring
infinity awareness exploring infinity
the one infinite creator expressing its
itself and so it'll be interesting to
see that
unfold in these next couple of decades
everyone that thinks that
they they know uh is going to be shocked
in the next couple of decades
what actually unfolds and so
we'll see what happens it's an
interesting hypothesis
so i love you tons thanks for tuning in
super appreciate it please let me know
your thoughts in the comments below this
is a very sacred episode to me
the unity of all finding is a sacred
sacred episode to me because it
literally marks
my leveling up it marks
my more deep self-realization
so i'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on where this lands for
you
let me know if it you know if this video
really landed for you
like the video subscribe if you haven't
already share the video with other
people
it's a really important thing for us to
continue
not only flourishing as simulation but
also achieving
all the things that we have lined up for
2021 and beyond i
we need your help so get the word out
and also check out all the links in the
bio below to the things that i was
talking about you'll see
some of the show notes down there so
check out those links down there
uh and also do a deeper dive into the
sufi metaphysics and also into the other
planetary metaphysical
traditions because what you'll find is
you'll find some of these most profound
most enriching
self-realizations that are catalysts
for the awakening and that will heal
many of the ethical dilemmas that we
have in our modern social fabric
and support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
engineers scientists in your communities
and around the world that are building
the future that are manifesting their
dreams into the world you can support us
all of our links are in the bio below
as well that's it i love you so much fam
thank you for being here with me for
this
i super duper duper
appreciate you being here with me for
this
it was one of the most profound
experiences of my life and the fact that
i get to market with this video
is super meaningful to me it's super
artistic for me
it feels hella good i hope it brought
you tremendous value
i love you tons i love you so much thank
you for being here early
huge things huge things coming
the unity of all finding